اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رام الله اهلا
بكم في اليوم الثاني من الهدنه المؤقته
حماس تتهم الاحتلال بخرق الهدنه وعدم
الالتزام بمعايير الافراج عن الاسرى
وايصال المساعدات وتحذر من ان ذلك يضع
الاتفاق برمته في خطر واسرائيل تعلن
اعتزامها الافراج عن 42 من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين مقابل الافراج عن اربعه
اسرائيليا تمار كبير يكشف عنه في مدينه
غزه وشمال القطاع 60% من المنازل لم تعد
صالحه للسكن هيئه المعابر بغزه تؤكد ان
المساعدات التي تدخل القطاع لا تكفي
الاحتياجات في حين تقول وزاره الصحه في
غزه للجزيره ان مستشفيات جنوب القطاع غير
قادره على استقبال المصابين الذين يتم
اجلاؤهم
من
الشمال اسويت برس تنقل عن مسؤول دفاعي
امريكي قوله ان سفينه حاويات مملوكه لرجل
اعمال اسرائيلي تعرضت امس لهجوم بمسيره في
المحيط الهندي مضيفا ان السفينه التي ترفع
علم مالطا يشتبه في انها استهدفت بطائره
مسيره من طراز شاهد
136 واوشي بريس تشير الى ان انفجار
الطائره المسيره ادى الى الحاق اضرار
بالسفينه دون اصابه اي من افراد طاقمها
تزامنا مع الهدنه في غزه قوات الاحتلال
تقتل طبيبا فلسطينيا وتصيب اخرين في
قباطيه وحمله دهم واعتقالات في مناطق
متفرقه بالضفه الغربيه نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني يقول ان قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت
17 فلسطينيا بالض الغربيه ما يرفع عدد
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين الى اكثر من
3160 منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى
اللقاء